youtube fam it's hans kim professional  cave spelunker  we're all here escaping coronavirus  together  and this is the view  check out all the people that are here  just built another raging cajun  bd this is my sharp stick  hitting her up  [Music]  what's up i'm on top of this hill right  next to my  car that's my car right there  what's up this is hans kim i'm just here  in the mountains of  the colorado desert just trying to keep  it real  [Music]  found it  all the way up and around i'm here the  ancient ruins  of the white people here i am at the  entrance of a cave  so it looks it just looks like that  looks pretty cool  i'm in a cave [ __ ]  hello hello i'm in a cave  it's not just me in a cave it's just a  different kind of me